with the eternals headed to the silver
screen the sorceress known as cersei is
about to become a big deal to marvel
fans but who is this ancient superhero
and what's her story from the odyssey to
the avengers this is the history of
marvel's cersei explained the first run
of eternals begins with icarus on an
expedition with a scientist named daniel
damian and his daughter margot icarus
explains the threat posed by the race
known as the deviants who like the
eternals were created by the celestials
but where the eternals are good powerful
and kind the deviants are cruel hideous
and prone to mutation knowing a war is
coming icarus takes margo to cersei so
that she might keep the mortal girl safe
in her chic manhattan apartment
cersei agrees to do so and proceeds to
blow margot's mind by reminiscing about
the time she turned odysseus's crew into
pigs as well as the time she taught
merlin during her stint at king arthur's
court margot is of course floored by all
this especially since cersei appears to
be little more than a gal about town
who's prone to practicing her dance
moves during idol hours at home when the
deviants attack her apartment however
cersei further reveals her skills as a
warrior barraging her foes with cosmic
energy blocking their blasts of flame
and transforming them all into animals
old habits die hard apparently
cersei is legendary for her parties and
these shindigs aren't just fun either as
they often serve the plot of the stories
in which they appear for example during
one particularly raucous gathering
cersei is introduced to marvel heroes
such as the wasp she-hulk and star fox
who she learns as a fellow eternal the
party is interrupted when the eternals
attempt to summon her to participate in
the uni mind a kind of merging of their
souls but she ignores it undaunted the
eternals known as the delphin brothers
crash the party cersei is made to join
the uni mind which results in the
eternals deciding to leave earth cersei
refuses to go along with this however as
she enjoys living among humans way too
much to leave this encounter put cersei
on the avengers radar when captain
america needs help finding a bunch of
kids in 1989's captain america number
355 he turns to cersei to transform him
into a teenager later in avengers number
314 she actually joins the avengers at
cap's invitation it just goes to show
you one great party can change
everything
avengers
after the eternal and avenger known as
gilgamesh is severely injured his
teammates turned to cersei to help heal
him his condition is beyond her
abilities to fix but she does later
agree to join the avengers in his
absence facing the space pirate nebula
in her first mission cersei saves the
team from total obliteration and helps
restore reality in the process for a
while things go swimmingly for cersei
she handles mother night's brainwashing
tricks banishes radioactive foes
alongside thor and helps a demon called
the unspeakable one merge with his
literal better half all along cersei
remains her bubbly whip smart self and
she proves to be a major team asset
despite how different she is from the
rest of the avengers in short cersei
loves the heroics she loves the people
and she's awfully good at saving the day
but all that changes in her next mission
as an avenger
in a storyline beginning with 1991's
avengers number 334 the team faces an
alien race called the brethren led by
the charismatic thane ector soon after
capturing cersei thane ekdor falls in
love with her and she too realizes they
have a mysterious connection it is later
revealed that the brethren are also
creations of the celestials and the
collector and old avengers foe is
manipulating them to destroy earth
cersei forms the uni mind with the
brethren to defeat the collector despite
the fact that forming the unimined with
another species is forbidden to eternals
cersei's behavior changes in the
aftermath of this event she becomes more
violent and unstable even as she starts
to fall for her fellow avenger dane
whitman things are thrown into outright
chaos when the avengers get involved in
a huge interstellar war between the cree
and shiar which turns out to be a ruse
concocted by the cree's supreme
intelligence when the avengers learn of
this plot a breakaway group including
cersei kills him and this tears the
avengers apart complicating things
further dane develops feelings for new
teammate crystal and against his better
judgment starts a romance with cersei
too this does little to calm cersei who
soon grows even more troubled when the
team travels to a distant dimension and
fails to stop a young girl from being
sacrificed by a priest cersei ends up
killing the priest in revenge
after killing the priest cersei flees to
wakanda dane talks her into coming back
but upon her return she inexplicably
attacks the avengers she's eventually
defeated by an imposter of the vision
who has been sent to infiltrate the team
it turns out that anti-vision is one of
the gatherers whose leader the
mysterious proctor is hell-bent on
terrorizing cersei cersei's fellow
eternals icarus arex and sprite arrive
and demand the avengers hand cersei over
to them icarus says she is suffering
from a form of insanity found in
eternals called the mad weary and that
it was probably caused by her use of the
unimined now her fellow eternals plan to
take her home to olympia and have her
cleansed which means disintegrating her
at a molecular level the eternal
equivalent of execution the avengers
don't like the sound of this and a short
fight ensues only ending when sprite
reads cersei's mind and realizes she's
in love with dane without asking his
permission it corresponds dane to cersei
as her gan joseon or soulmate dane who
had just made a move on crystal is
forced into following a terrifying
imperative be with cersei or let her die
cersei's life continues to spiral out of
control especially after she's connected
to the deaths of two detectives and when
the police arrive to arrest her for the
killings she responds by leveling
avengers mansion and destroying the
brooklyn bridge dane remains by her side
forced by their bond into standing with
her until cersei goes after crystal that
is only then does dane realize that she
needs to be stopped at this point the
enigmatic proctor captures her and
reveals himself as the dane whitman of
an alternate universe he was rejected by
the cersei of his world so he made it
his mission to drive her insane in every
other reality using powers stolen from a
watcher at last cersei knows her erratic
behavior is not her fault but the damage
has been done regardless cersei kills
him with his own ebony blade and exiles
herself to another dimension the dane of
her world his own mind cleared by
proctor's death opts to join her
cersei and dane enter the ultraverse of
malibu comics home to an alternate earth
and a whole other cast of superheroes
the journey has the desired effect as
cersei is able to exist dimensions away
from proctor's control and so finally
comes to her senses that clarity doesn't
last long unfortunately as she's
immediately possessed by a heretofore
unknown infinity gem called the ego gem
subsequently the other infinity gems are
transported to the ultraverse along with
the trickster god loki surprise
loki obtains the other six gems and the
possessed cersei sends a superhero team
called ultraforce led by dane after him
when the grandmaster travels to the
ultraverse to seek his old mind gem he
proposes a contest to loki his pawns
will be the avengers zapped to the
ultraverse while loki's team will be
ultraforce loki wins but it turns out
that this was all a ruse for cersei to
get close enough for the ego gem to
reunite with the other legendary stones
the gem becomes a sentient god-like
being named nemesis nemesis combines the
two universes but can't quite hold them
together and is ultimately defeated when
dane cuts off her crown with the ebony
blade that splits the gems apart once
again reconstitutes the ultraverse and
gives dean and cersei the chance to
return home
when they return to earth cersei and
dane don't arrive in the present day
instead they find themselves in the
midst of the crusades dane's mind winds
up in the body of a crusader ancestor
named eobar gerrington and it takes
cersei convincing ayobar's spirit to
move on before dane can assert himself
ayobar's best friend and fellow crusader
bene du perry isn't pleased about all
this as the pair had been on their way
to find the eternal pharaoh in his tower
of power dane's accidental takeover of
aobar's body spells the end of that
quest angering binet who goes on by
himself binet is then found by the
pharaoh who turns out to be the mutant
supervillain apocalypse
i
have returned
he activates benay's latent mutant
powers and binay becomes the powerful
telepath exodus apocalypse orders him to
kill dane and cersei but he refuses to
kill his old friend
so as punishment apocalypse strips him
of his powers and traps him in suspended
animation for the next 900 years exodus
would later be freed by magneto in an
x-factor storyline from the early 90s in
the end cersei and dane managed to
return to their rightful time albeit
once again in different places the trip
tears apart their gan joseon link too
and cersei and dane decide to split up
for good
left with nowhere else to go cersei
returns to olympia at the time
apocalypse is busy turning deviants into
mindless monsters who've begun attacking
humans and so the eternals pose as a new
team of superheroes called the new breed
joining them cersei takes the code name
mesmer this lasts until the mischievous
eternal known as sprite pulls his
ultimate prank in the lead up to the
2006 eternals series erasing the
memories of every eternal as a result
cersei becomes a mild-mannered party
planner ignorant of her powers and
origin when one of her parties is
attacked by terrorists makari her former
lover and fellow eternal helps stop them
iron man then shows up to question
makari who is living an amnesiac life as
mark curry stark recognizes cersei as a
former avenger but is shocked to
discover that there is no record of her
in any of the team's files as it turns
out this is all a deviant ruse designed
to awaken the dreaming celestial who has
been banished to earth for speaking out
against the abuse of deviants when
makari convinces the dreaming celestial
to wait 50 years before passing judgment
on earth cersei decides to give up super
heroics once and for all she goes back
to her party planning job and other than
occasionally advising the avengers keeps
her promise to stay retired in 2018's
avengers number one the bodies of dead
celestials begin raining down on earth
who could have killed these omnipotent
beings so easily as it turns out it was
the final host of dark celestials ready
to wipe out the earth for good the
avengers learn that these celestials
serve a transcendent being called the
fulcrum and their job is to not only
experiment on young worlds but to
destroy them after millions of years in
order to reap their energy the fulcrum
also created a race of insect creatures
called the horde and the dark celestials
came about when the horde infected a
number of celestials the eternals
learned that their true purpose wasn't
to protect humanity after all but to
cultivate them like crops for the good
of these celestials this realization
drives them all mad leading to each of
their deaths thanks to icarus's last
words iron man is able to determine a
way for humans to form the uni mind he
is then told that something in human dna
can stop the horde and the avengers
managed to save the day sometime later
cersei and her fellow eternals are
resurrected by the machines that give
their kind their immortality after a
short conflict with thanos however
icarus discovers another horrifying
truth behind their existence essentially
that a human being is killed every time
an eternal is resurrected icarus decides
this process is pretty much unacceptable
and he cersei and their fellow eternals
set out to solve the problem once and
for all check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite marvel comics
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you